[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
Kartoffelsuppe auf die türkische Art ich
habe gedacht ein Suppenrezept darf
dieses Jahr Ramadan einfach nicht fehlen
man startet ja nach dem richtig langen
und auch sehr anstrengenden Fastentag
immer mit einer Suppe und den Magen auf
das Essen vorzubereiten und diese
Kartoffelsuppe ist super schnell und
einfach gemacht also ich würde vorab
hier schon mal die ganzen Vorbereitungen
treffen ich würde die Zwiebeln schon mal
Würfeln ihr müsst es auch nicht so fein
machen es wird sowieso alles püriert was
ich auch vorbereite ist ähm die
Kartoffeln schälen und würfeln und dann
zeige ich euch wie es weitergeht das ist
wirklich ein Witz Rezept und es schmeckt
sehr sehr lecker
[Musik]
so weiter geht es jetzt hier am Herd
Knoblauch habe ich gerade auch ganz grob
nur gewürfelt wie gesagt es wird eh
alles püriert daher mega easy heute und
entspannt ich gebe jetzt hier die Butter
in meine in meinen Topf und da auch
nicht zu hohe Hitze verwenden damit sie
euch nicht verbrennt dann lasse ich das
hier langsam schmelzen und anschließend
kommt meisten Mehl dazu das ist auch ich
habe das Gefühl dass es in der
türkischen Küche viel öfter vorkommt als
jetzt irgendwie in der deutschen und das
gebe ich dann gleich mit dazu und dann
machen wir eine Art Mehlschwitze
allerdings diesmal nicht mit normal
sondern mit Maismehl und das ganze dann
bis es schön röstet und dann kommt
später noch zwiebeln und Knoblauch dazu
[Musik]
zwiebeln und Knoblauch durften jetzt
auch noch mal zwei Minuten lang darin
anschwitzen und ihr könnt an der Stelle
auch schon mal Kartoffeln dazugeben
nehmt gerne mehlig kochende ansonsten
würden auch vorwiegend festkochende
gehen oder wenn ihr nur festkochende
Damen das ist auch okay aber die Milch
kochen und eignen sich super für Suppen
ich gebe da jetzt auch schon Salz und
Pfeffer mit dazu und löscht das ganze
mit Wasser ab wenn ihr zufällig
Hühnerbrühe da habt weil ihr gerade
gekocht habt für das Essen dann gibt es
auch gerne mit dazu und ähm dann
schmeckt es auch noch mal sehr lecker
aber ich habe gerade nicht da deswegen
funktioniert auch so sondern kann das
Ganze vor sich hin köcheln dort habe ich
das weiß klein geschnitten haben auch
nur so 10 Minuten und danach püriere ich
das ganze auch schon
[Musik]
so nach 10 Minuten können wir schon
pürieren das coole ist ihr braucht ganz
wenig Materialeinsatz also wenig Zutaten
hat ganz viel Suppe und durch das
Maismehl ist die Suppe nicht nur schön
gelb passt natürlich auch zu Kartoffel
sondern auch super sämig ich habe gerade
noch immer wieder ein bisschen Wasser
nachgefüllt müssen natürlich auch mit
dem Salz noch mal abschmecken und ja
dann habt ihr einfach ein riesen Topf
voll Suppe mit echt ganz wenig Zutaten
ich püriere das ganze jetzt und dann
zeige ich euch noch mal wie wir das
ganze auf türkische Art verfeinern
wir brauchen jetzt gutes Olivenöl ich
entscheide mich heute von meinem
palästinensisches das passt irgendwie
Türkisch und palästinensische Küche
passt der perfekt zu haben sondern mir
ich habe das jetzt hier einmal in meine
Pfanne dann wird das erwärmt und dann
rösten wir darin Paprika Pulver ein an
der kommt edelsüßes Paprika Pulver rein
und wenn es scharf mögt noch so ein paar
Flocken Pulver das sind scharfe Paprika
Flocken und dann kommt es einfach noch
mal wie beim Mantel noch mal oben drüber
auf die Suppe als Abschluss es gibt auch
noch mal Geschmack sieht aber auch
optischer mega gut aus
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Ersten Deutschen
Fernsehen so haben solche
gemacht
lecker schmecken zu bekommen
auf die türkische Art und ich habe jetzt
hier noch ja aber palästinentes Oliven
aber es ist normal
okay jetzt die nennt sich das Wasser
aber was ist einfach Olivenöl Paprika ne
ja so ein bisschen angeröstet also ich
habe meine jetzt umgerührt damit
natürlich
[Musik]
ist nicht nur Gewürz mit Salz und
Pfeffer das also es ist einfach diese
Eigengeschmack der Kartoffel von den
Zwiebeln Knoblauch ist Maismehl Zitrone
oder kein Salz mehr das ist perfekt also
wirklich perfekt gemacht Zitrone hast du
so von der türkischen Linsensuppe ne
also ganz ehrlich
probieren ne wenn man wirklich
nicht
essen
also okay
ich habe ich mache das immer aber meine
Stimme kein Teelöffel anzugeben
meine Mutter immer
machst du mit mega geil und ich glaube
die Suppe wird sehr gut aus
das schmeckt man das schmeckt man auch
raus finde ich lecker
ich wünsche euch jetzt viel Spaß und ich
würde mal sagen Leute abonniert den
Kanal wenn es bis jetzt noch nicht
gemacht habt Leute
aber ihr könnt doch einfach abonnieren
also bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]